la quatrième tentative aura été la bonne
moscou a finalement ouvert un corridor
humanitaire a soumis dans le nord-est de
l'ukraine une première depuis le début
de l'invasion
environ 5000 personnes non 1700
étudiants étrangers sont partis en
convoi le cessez-le-feu temporaire a
essentiellement été respectée
les évacués ont pu constater les dégâts
mais aussi la férocité des combats près
de la ville assiégée en voyant les
carcasses de chars d'assaut russes
du thym de guerre des soldats ukrainiens
ont mis la main sur des caisses de
munitions abandonnées
la crise humanitaire prend de l'ampleur
chaque jour plus de 2 millions
d'ukrainiens ont fui leur pays en 12
jours maurice g russe est comme
méliand ce moment où elles free
ils vivent centre névralgique de l'ouest
du pays est dépassé deux cent mille
réfugiés vivent temporairement 58
l'autre ils transitent chaque jour une
partie du bâtiment intérieur du stade de
football de lviv a été transformé en
centre d'accueil plaque tournante pour
des milliers de réfugiés qui passent ici
pour ensuite rejoindre d'autres pays
sacha n'a quitté son domicile que pour
protéger sa fille de 4 ans l'usa déjà
capable d'identifier le calibre des
différentes munitions à son âge
pour l'instant
elle ne remerciera jamais assez ces bons
samaritains
au stade de football les réfugiés sont
logés nourris et habillé temporairement
le temps de trouver un endroit où vivre
plus souvent qu'autrement à l'étranger
daniel lui prêt à en faire davantage
c'est lui fend le coeur de voir tant de
jeunes enfants évacués tuning
excuse un autre la force d'un
des réfugiés arrivent à l'église jean
paul 2 2 vivent ils pourront y rester
aussi longtemps qu'il le désire on
dans sa chambre qu'elle partage avec six
autres membres de sa famille annie un
veille sur son mac art qui n'a que deux
mois elle espère pouvoir retrouver son
mari bientôt
même si elle est épuisée elle essaie de
garder espoir
pour ce flot incessant de réfugiés
ukrainien c'est tout ce qu'il leur reste
l'espoir aussi minime soit-il par
moments ici philippe leblanc radio
canada vivent en ukraine